the uk government claims it has
recognised the threat posed by russia
for a long time
and considers moscow a security priority
it also says too
it has a 30-year strategy for dealing
with the kremlin
well this was london's response to a
report on alleged russian meddling in
british politics that was released on
tuesday
it accuses the uk of failing to take the
threat
seriously who is protecting
british public from interference in our
democratic process
well in a nutshell we found no one is
the uk government took its eye off the
ball
because of its focus on counter
terrorism we found the defense
of the uk democratic process is a hot
potato the government had badly
underestimated the response required to
the russian threat
and is still playing catch up the
outrage
isn't that there was interference the
outrage is that no one
want to know if there was well the
russia report there had been sat on by
the government for a year and a half
before it was
finally released on tuesday artist dan
hawkins looks at what it said
to get a very brief summary of the
long-awaited russia reports
we can go straight to page 13 of the
document
the written evidence provided to us
appeared to suggest that her majesty's
government had not seen
or sought evidence of successful
interference
in uk democratic processes seems to be
enough
so if you're short on time or don't want
to read heavily redacted intelligence
and political spiel
stop watching now otherwise let's go on
open source studies have pointed to the
preponderance of pro-brexit or anti-eu
stories on rt and sputnik and the use of
bots and trolls as evidence of russian
attempts to influence the process
we have sought to establish whether
there is secret intelligence
which supported or built on these
studies in response
mi5 initially provided just six lines of
text
the report's authors were seemingly
surprised by the limited response of the
intelligence services
but not because those agencies may have
more important priorities such as
protecting lives by
tackling international domestic
terrorism or serious crime
apparently more resources are needed to
keep track of social media
and rt's editorial policies and coverage
brexit polarized millions with
several broadcasters coming under fire
but it's still russia that poses the
risk
and the security services that aren't
doing their job
this is about the protection of the uk's
democratic process
and mechanism from hostile state
interference
which should fall to our intelligence
and security
agencies after all moscow's been waging
influence campaigns
targeting uk politics through digital
media
wealthy individuals organizations and
almost
any other means the report warns the
threat of russian influence is a hot
potato with intelligence and other
agencies shirking the responsibility of
taking the lead in tackling it
and reassuring the public amid
widespread allegations
though again the impact of such
influence remains
elusive the impact of any such attempts
would be difficult if not impossible
to assess and we have not sought to do
so
state agencies haven't looked closely
enough at open source
information according to the report they
lacked retrospective assessment
and intelligence agencies in particular
need a more important role
in future the committee was struck by
the relatively small proportion
of work that is carried out by the
agencies in relation to russia in any
case
should they consider other threats to be
a higher priority
they can always fall back on trusted
russia experts to lead the way
christopher steele author of the
infamous anonymous golden shower dossier
and contributors to the institute for
statecraft and integrity initiative
a project founded to tackle the russian
threat
receiving state funding to advise the
state that russia
is a threat moscow's response was swift
and predictable
as was the final conclusion of the
long-awaited russia report
showing yet again that any reproachment
with the uk
however small is still beyond the
horizon
and hawkins there we've got reaction on
the streets of london to the claims that
were made
in the report to be honest i don't
believe it
because it's just more it's either more
distractions
from what's really going on and the fact
they're always trying to paint
russia is that the the spy the enemy
i just think we can't get it right so
why should they interfere
and it's got nothing to do with them why
wait till now
if they were tailing us now why didn't
they tell us at the beginning people are
aware that um
you know other countries will interfere
with the politics of others people will
try to influence for their own
government's interests the former
british ambassador to uzbekistan and
human rights advocate
craig murray believes that the uk is
determined to ruin
any relations with russia the report is
you know extremely unconvincing in
itself in that it
doesn't even purport to give any
evidence of
what it claims to be happening i think
it's a
you know it's fairly laughable there's
nothing concrete in it
the uk is determined uh to uh
ruin your uk russian relations you must
remember there are people
in the armaments industry and the
security industry
who make a lot of money out of having
russia
as an enemy you know the the security
industry in the armaments
industry need an enemy in order to get
the rest of us mugs
to pay them billions and billions in our
taxes
every year but they suck out of the
system and that's what this is about
this is about portraying
an enemy in fact there's no reason at
all for enmity between the uk and russia
and certainly no
inventory between the uk people and the
russian people
you